hello everyone and welcome to a really
interesting game that took place in the
chest 24 banter blitz match between
Magnus Carlsen and Grandmaster Peppa
cuenca now this is round two in round
one
pepper cuenca defeated his opponent
georgian grandmaster 11 pencil ayah with
a score of 9 to 0 so Magnus definitely
took this match seriously and this is a
game
well obviously from the match it's uh
it's the first game of the match and
it's the one where Magnus said that he's
just gonna try a quick attack showing
little to no respect as the position
allowed it so without further ado let's
check it out Magnus opens with b4 now we
have Knight to f6 and Bishop to g5 he
goes for the trump offski and he
mentions briefly that he didn't check
what Queen cap plays so that's why he's
gonna go for a slow slow line the five
in the night the d two most common is
just captures on f6 so Knight d2 we have
e 6 e 3 and now Bishop to e7 just making
room for castling with c3 and now of
Cuenca castles Bishop to d3 by Magnus
and b6 now preparing the ship to be 7
and denied study for now with f4 by
Magnus grabbing more control of the e5
square
there's up the b7 and now Magnus
mentions in the video that he decides to
capture on f6 he doesn't want allowed
the knight to lend on e4 so just Bishop
captures captures and the knight g2 f3
we have c5 by black and now h4 and
already Magnus mentions that maybe some
Bishop to h7 action is possible here
what he means by this is if black plays
something like 97 he can sacrifice the
bishop on h7 and if King captures Knight
g5 will be very strong the Queen can
come to h5 and it's a well known Bishop
sacrifice where if you go back with the
King then just Queen h5 and black will
have very you know big difficulties
defending this position if you capture
just H captures you open up the H file
for the rook so you'd have to play
something like this but then you allow
Queen captures on f7 and then after the
King moves the knight comes to f3 and is
just a very strong position for white
which would of course be winning in the
end so
even if you allow that you would have to
go for something like captors captors 95
check engage six and even though this is
good for black in a three-minute blitz
game
it's it should not be playable
especially not against against a strong
man a grandmaster and especially not
against the world chess champion or King
get stuck on h6 and you will waste a lot
of time trying to defend this
so after h4 Cuenca goes for h6 he just
defends it we have G for preparing g5
and Bishop to e7
so if g5 comes you can advance the pawn
to h5 you don't have to worry about your
piece being under attack we have g5 by
Magnus and now h5 of course you don't
want to open up lines in front of your
king and now Knight to e5 and the g6 are
both excellent excellent moves
Magnus decides to go for g6 and now F
captures and g6 if if you try f5 to try
to keep the position close just Knight
e5 and then it's it's a pretty
straightforward victory victory for
white so after g6 with F captors and g6
Bishop captures and g6 and the now
Knight to d7 we have nice the g5 again
black doesn't achieve anything by it by
trading here you just open up the H file
for your rook and then it's just over
so here Knight to f6 adds another
defender to the position you will be
controlling the h7 square which is
really important and also you're not
just allowing the Queen to infiltrate
with Queen captures on age 5 and here
Cuenca allows Knight captures and e6 but
Magnus isn't interested in a winning
material since if something like this
then yes he wins d exchanged but he
developed all of black's pieces and he
doesn't want to do that he prefers to
keep the initiative so Bishop captures
on h5 and now comes Queen to d6
developing and now the other rook can
also come into the game a game + or he
wants to exchange lights worships with
this maneuver so Bishop to g6 now Magnus
makes a room for the Aged point to start
marching forward we have brush up to c6
with the plan of Bishop - eh and now h5
with bishop t8 and now Queen to b1 a
nice move that allows White's to
continue the advancement of the H pawn
because now the bishop is protected
you're just gonna push here capture open
up eh file and continue in that fashion
capturing doesn't do anything as the
Queen very easily takes the bishops
place and then just h6 so we see capture
Sun before and now while h6 is possible
immediately you don't want to waste too
much time calculating you know in a
three minute blitz game so see capture
son d4 and rook the c8 and here it's
best for whites to just capture on e8
and but Magnus decides to push h6 right
away and this allows pepper Cuenca a
very interesting well exchange sacrifice
that allows him to stay in the game so
here he plays rook the c1 with check
removes the defender of the bishop on g6
so you have to capture it Queen captures
and now Bishop captures on g6 that's why
it was better just to capture and then
push h6 as you would not have this
maneuver so we have bishop to caption g
6h captures on g17 captures and now
Knight D comes to f3
Magnus also briefly mentions that Queen
to c7 also playable where black would
have to trade Queens and then you just
grab another pawn with check and then
you pick up the Queen you're a bee
exchange so you can just go into an
endgame but he goes for this line
instead an ID of three Queen before with
check with King to have to end now
Knight to g4 with check King g3 the king
is very safe there and now Knight to h6
coming to f5 with check but here Magnus
just plays Knight captures on e6 and it
was in this position that pepper clink I
resigned the game as there is nothing
more he can do here the rook is under
attack if the King moves you you can
pick up the night you can come to c7
with the Queen so it's just it's just an
unplayable position for black so this is
the first game of the match Magnus won
it and in the end after nine games the
result was eight and a half at half for
Magnus so one game was wrong
the other eight games were won by Magnus
and yes I don't know if you've heard but
Magnus Carlsen is currently I don't know
if he still is but today he posted that
he is the number one player in the world
in fantasy league football
whatever that is I don't know I haven't
played it but sounds sounds like well if
you're first in anything in the world
that's worth mentioning so just I
thought I'd put the put it in there as
well and also if you are interested in
checking out the other games from this
match I will put a link in the
description below with a link to the
chess 24 website where you can check it
all out and also if you want to check
out the exact video of Magnus Carlsen
stream I will also put that in the
description so you can also check that
out so now that's the game a very nice
attack and it really was a quick attack
where a little to no respect was shown
so there we have it I do hope you enjoy
that I would like to thank Rohan Padano
met back with Scott in cell 6g GmbH and
Rohan ban Charlie for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see soon are
continuing with the coverage of the well
Frieda Graham pretty checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world such as this
look of this match here and do be a part
of the subscribers video 2020 it's going
to be awesome so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day